[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat les missions qui
vous fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée on va parler de pornographie
ce matin puisque les sénateurs entament
leur travail sur les violences sexuelles
dans le monde du film pornographique
les sénateurs ont auditionné à des
associations féministes sur ce sujet un
véritable sujet puisque une cinquantaine
de victimes ont déjà été identifiés huit
producteurs et acteurs sont actuellement
mises en examen je vous laisse écouter
cette audition bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci de nous avoir invités à
participer à cette table ronde
notre propos va être plutôt généraliste
dans un premier temps puis nous
laisserons donc la marrade les autres
associations allée plus concrètement sur
ce que vous avez évoqué notamment le
procès en cours et les pratiques de
l'industrie pornographique
mais dans un premier temps il nous
paraissait important de reposer un peu
le cadre du sujet et puis de vous
expliquer aussi pourquoi au mouvement du
nid nous avons commencé il ya déjà un
certain nombre d'années à travailler
cette question un peu plus d'une part
parce qu'il se trouve que notre
délégation en région était de plus en
plus sollicités par des personnes qui
avaient été
victimes de l'industrie pornographique
et qui cherchait de l'aide et du soutien
et de l'accompagnement et puis parce que
quand nous intervenons sur la question
de la prostitution
cette question de la pornographie nous
et est régulièrement posée est ce que
vous faites un lien est ce que c'est la
même chose quelle est votre position
nous n'avions pas de position officielle
en tant qu'association même si en tant
qu association féministe évidemment nous
avions une idée sur la question et donc
nous avons démarré un travail pour
pouvoir arriver à une position
officielle et je vais tout de suite et
c'est la parole à sandrine d'autres
chemises pour vous faire un petit état
de nos réflexions et de la position à
laquelle nous sommes arrivés
[Musique]
merci beaucoup clair dont jours à toutes
et à tous merci madame la présidente
mesdames les sénatrices et membre de la
délégation pour avoir organisé cette
table ronde je vais donc vous parler de
la mise en place de cette position
officielle du mouvement des nids sur la
prostitution filmer et de ses
conséquences aujourd'hui qui seront
utiles pour répondre à vos
questionnements l'association a mis en
place une commission en 2015 que j'ai eu
la chance d'animer une commission
chargée par l'assemblée générale de
préparer une position officielle du
mouvement du nid sur le sujet en 2016 à
angers cette position est adoptée par
l'assemblée générale alors que la loi du
13 avril 2016 de renforcement de la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
vient tout juste d'être votée et la
concomitance de ces deux événements est
importante la loi votée elle dit que
tout achat d'acte sexuel est interdite
or les travaux du mouvement du nid ont
permis de comprendre que dans ce qu'on
appelle communément l'industrie du porno
ya tous les niveaux achat d'acte sexuel
proxénétisme et violence prostitutionnel
en effet dans les années qui précèdent
la loi les équipes de terrain comme l'a
dit claire du mouvement du nid le
mouvement du nid je le rappelle
accompagne plus de 1200 personnes en
situation de prostitution chaque année
donc nos équipes de terrain nous ont
régulièrement fait remonter des
témoignages de personnes qu'elle
s'accompagnait faisant état de ses liens
étroits entre prostitution et
pornographie celle qui venait à
l'association pour être accompagnés et
où être aidée à sortir de la
prostitution racontait souvent avons été
explosés aussi dans la pornographie
par ailleurs pour celles qui n'avaient
pas directement été exploitées elles
pouvaient avoir été filmées parfois à
leur insu ou pas et que ce soit ensuite
c'est c'est l'idée au cern de chantage
pour les maintenir dans la constitution
dans le même temps dans la société en
général on parle un peu du porno mais
jamais pour cet aspect de prostitution
proxénétisme et violence ce qui
préoccupe certains acteurs sociaux c'est
le fait que de plus en plus de jeunes
soient exposés à des vidéos de plus en
plus tôt parfois au sein d'associations
féministes s'y ajoutent éthique des
représentations dégradantes et
déshumanisante des femmes dans le porno
pour le mouvement du nid cette double
dénonciation aussi fondamentale est
juste soit elle qui n'est pas suffisante
car il ya tout cet aspect qui s'y
rapportent et qui a encore largement
passé sous silence proxénétisme
prostitution violence sexuelle un
instinct me correspond plus encore faux
couple et deux autres à l'objet social
de notre association lutter contre les
causes et les conséquences de la
prostitution
remonte donc sur la réalité de
l'industrie porno c'est une industrie de
production de films dont la
particularité est de ne pas être du
cinéma les actes sexuels sont réels les
pénétrations sont réels les coûts et les
tortures aux voies sont réels le tout
est produit pour obtenir un maximum
d'audience et donc développer un marché
et un chiffre d'affaires qui sont
colossaux pour cela il faut recruter ce
qu'on appelle des actrices ou des
acteurs qui sont en réalité des
personnes à qui l'on demande un
consentement on extorque un consentement
par contre alors voulu d'avira
vulnérabilité parce qu'elles ont besoin
d'argent parce qu'elles soient en
situation de fragilité et on sent ce
faux consentement des actes violents et
sans désir
et cela on le voit très vite constitue
non seulement une violence en soi comme
l'est la prostitution mais une violence
décuplée dans la pornographie
pour comprendre cela les témoignages
sont fondamentaux nous plions nous
publions dans notre revue prostitution
et société en 2016 le témoignage de
nadia qui dit le xc des viols à
répétition c'est inhumain ce sera le
témoignage est de loin le plus lu sur
notre site je vous en cite un extrait
mois la beurette entre guillemets
j'étais la seule arabe le porno est un
milieu fermé et très raciste mais ils
utilisent toutes sortes de femmes j'en
ai même vu une de 200 kg et il réunit
toutes les perversions imaginables quand
on se rebelle on nous dit ya de la
demande il ya ce qu'on appelle le gonzo
on prend des coups très violents on se
fait cracher dessus tiré par les cheveux
j'ai tourné comme seule femme avec 35
type tous masqués j'ai eu la peau brûlée
par le sperme j'avais dit pas de scato
pas du ropa de zoophilie il a fallu que
je me batte sans arrêt j'ai connu une
fille il s'est suicidé après avoir
tourné des scènes avec un chien le truc
tournait sur internet elle avait 18 ans
maintenant je réalise que la
pornographie c'est de l' esclavage
moderne j'ai été vraiment humiliée à
côté j'ai trouvé que dans la
prostitution il y avait au moins des
hommes gentils j'ai été violée une seule
fois j'ai pas été torturé le hic c'est
déjà la répétition c'est inhumain
ce témoignage est notre expérience
vis-à-vis des personnes accompagnées au
mouvement du nid ainsi que tous ces
témoignages qui ont été recueillis dans
les plaintes liées à la sphère french
[__] dont mes camarades parlerons
plus tout à leur permettent de répondre
à votre question ou madame la présidente
oui ces violences sont non seulement
extrêmement répondu mais elles sont la
règle dans certains districts à
l'exception
par ailleurs on le voit encore
aujourd'hui dans la sphère qui nous
occupe le porno c'est aussi du
proxénétisme ces mêmes et c'est un
sociologue qui n'est pas abolitionnistes
qui lui dit du proxénétisme à l'échelle
industrielle
sony perd saïdi en effet sont concernés
ceux qui organisent diffuse font la
publicité ou ceux qui en bénéficient
producteur réalisateur maquilleur
cameramen tous les diffuseurs chaînes de
télé les réseaux de diffusion par câble
satellite tooway retiennent une grande
partie des réseaux de distribution de la
presse les techniciens qui contribuent à
la production mais aussi les
appartements utilisé pour les tournages
répondent à la définition du
proxénétisme
en fait tout le monde parle pas alors
que les actrices gagnent de moins en
moins dit il
pornographie et prostitution sont donc
étroitement liés l'intention détonnant
de l'industrie et de la faire passer
pour une forme de liberté d'expression
de création il est fondamental de
renverser cette perspective et c'est ce
que nous avons souhaité faire il s'agit
de violences sexuelles qui sont
commandités le consentants et extorqué
par l'argent et l'exploitation de la
vulnérabilité et des violences extrêmes
soit infligée est subie à des femmes
profite
pour tout sept pour toutes ces raisons
il est plus approprié de parler de
prostitution film et que deux films
pornographiques terme qui fait passer
des violences sexuelles organisées pour
des productions culturelles
le fait que ces actes sexuels tarifés
soient obtenus dans le cadre de
l'industrie du film ne les ennuie j team
illégaux c'est en réalité selon nous un
facteur aggravant de la violence
l'afer qui arrive aujourd'hui est donc
un exemple extrême parce que les
violences sont extrêmes mais pas du tout
exceptionnelle dans le paysage de cette
industrie aux états unis guilde hines
une
chercheuse et psychologues le dénonce
depuis plus de dix ans encore une fois
pour le mouvement du nid il s'agit pas
d'une position de jugement moral sur des
pratiques sexuelles ou sur l'idée
pornographie représente et l'acte sexuel
n'est pas le problème en soi mais bien
le fait de commanditer des violences
sexuelles pour y parvenir nous
revendiquons qu'il est tout à fait
possible de représenter la sexualité
humaine sans recourir à ces procédés
après tout pas besoin de tuer pour
représenter le meurtre
avant de repasser la parole à claire sur
la prévention je voudrais aussi
souligner quelque chose suite à une de
vos questions sur le porno éthique et
féministe
celle de la possibilité d'une
pornographie respectueuse si les
affaires actuelles mais toujours des
actes d'une violence inouïe on parle de
torture et de barbarie et viol à grande
échelle commandité on pourrait penser
que le problème n'est que celui de la
violence des actes et pas de l'existence
même de ces productions en réalité cette
violence là ne peut pas être aménagé on
le sait dans le domaine de la
prostitution en général c'est la même
chose dans la prostitution en fils mais
pour en parler je voudrais brièvement
mentionné la charte éthique mise en
place par dorcel en réaction aux
affaires actuel et le film pleasure
sortie sur les écrans récemment cette
charte dite éthique dit le consentement
des acteurs et des actrices quant aux
pratiques sexuelles doit être claire
préalable libre et éclairé pour faire
respecter ce consentement l'article 2
pose pour principe le droit au contrat
doit y être écrit le consentement dans
ce contrat à telle ou telle pratique
sexuelle or le simple fait d'écrire un
consentement à une pratique sexuelle
dans le contrat annuler sa possibilité
même du consentement car cela signifie
que l'employeur peut se retourner contre
l'employé si celle ci ne respecte pas
les pratiques acceptées à l'avance
alors que pour que le consentement
matière soit ex us sexuelle est un sens
il faut qu'il soit à tout moment
réversible
les scènes dans le film pleasure sortie
sur les écrans fin 2021 montre bien le
piège le consentement des actrices est
demandée en un mot il est même filmé
pour être respectées pense-t-on en
réalité ça n'est qu'un moyen de pression
supplémentaire pour que les femmes au
moment où elle souhaite dire non et où
elles n'en peuvent plus s'entend dire
mais tu as signé tu avais accepté tu ne
sais pas ce que tu veux et donc c'est
une façon de l'ayrolle culpabiliser au
lieu de les soutenir
donc porno éthique c'est un porno qui
protège ses intérêts pour nos féministes
aux états unis ça fait des années que
c'est pratique et soi disant dans son
modèle les actrices auraient le droit de
choisir leur partenaire les positions
sexuelles qu'ils adoptent la fréquence
la durée des actes sauf que ça n'est pas
du tout ça dans les faits
rebecca ruiz man u nos tristes féministe
la visionner des scènes tournées dans
ces soi-disant conditions féministe l'a
bien constaté vient ni est différent du
mainstream pourquoi parce que si
l'actrice est censé choisir et téoz elle
est aussi là parce qu'elle a besoin de
gagner de l'argent et pour faire gagner
de l'argent à la production et pour cela
il faut que les films soient rentables
il faut donc que ce qu'elles choisissent
ressemble à ce qui est conforme à la
demande ce qui fait vendre donc si leur
choix et pendant le tournage ne de ne
pas effectuer d'actes sexuels parce que
le désir des ports rendez-vous parce
qu'elles n'ont pas envie qu'elles
veulent plus elles ne seront pas payées
elles seront pas réembaucher on le voit
aussi ça très bien dans le film pleasure
une réalisatrice
tristane taormine nommé parmi les plus
connus aux états unis reconnaît elle
même que la volonté de donner le pouvoir
aux actrices est illusoire aussi parce
que les producteurs qui donne l'argent
pour faire les films en veulent pour
leur argent et c'est eux qui commandent
dans son action le mouvement du nid
alors sur le terrain agit aussi en
prévention que vous le savez sur ce
sujet aussi depuis 2016 est depuis
longtemps beaucoup a été fait et donc je
vais vous attendre à la claire pour en
dire quelques mots également
merci beaucoup sandrine je voudrais
juste oui en effet faire un tout petit
focus sur les incidences de la
pornographie chez les jeunes à partir de
notes expérience
en prévention puisque l'on vende unis
intervient en prévention depuis 25 ans
maintenant dans les collèges dans les
lycées et autour des questions bien sûr
de la constitution mais de manière plus
large d'égalité fille garçon de respect
de des stéréotypes de genre des
violences sexistes et sexuelles
et bien sûr la question de la
pornographie est toujours abordé et
c'est vraiment à partir de cette
expérience que je voudrais souligner
très rapidement quelques points
concernant les répercussions chez les
jeunes alors pour respecter nos temps de
parole je vais être très très rapide et
donc j'ai bien conscience que ce que je
vais vous dire c'est un raccourci qui
mériteraient beaucoup plus de pouvoir
être expliquée mais je tiens à votre
disposition si vous le souhaitez un
document plus détaillée qui pourra
reprendre les propos que je vais exposer
maintenant je voudrais juste rappeler en
préambule que au sens très complet de
l'eau et metz la santé sexuelle c'est
promouvoir un état de bien-être physique
mental et social dans le domaine de la
sexualité une approche positive et
respectueuse des relations sexuelles
source de plaisir et sans risque libre
de toute coercition
discrimination ou violences je pense
qu'il ya pas besoin d'être spécialiste
de la question de la pornographie pour
constater que sa consommation ne va pas
contribuer à
forger une bonne santé sexuelle chez les
jeunes d'autant plus que vous l'avez
souligné madame la présidente l'accès à
la pornographie se fait de plus en plus
jeune et qu'il ya un décalage énorme
entre la maturité sexuelle des enfants
qui ont accès à ces scènes je voudrais
juste pour être brève parler de trois
types de répercussions que nous
constatons chez les jeunes et à travers
aussi toutes les réflexions qui peuvent
nous faire lorsque nous intervenons le
venons en milieu scolaire il ya d'une
part les répercussions sociales
on voit que se transforme la vision de
la sexualité qui n'est plus centrée sur
la rencontre avec l'autre mais plutôt
sur une performance individuelle qui se
joue d'ailleurs sous rencontre sa ou son
partenaire plutôt qu'avec la prise en
compte de l'autre de son désir de ses
attentes de ses limites disparaît au
profit d'une forme très scénarisé et
autocentrée de l'acte sexuel
et d'ailleurs on constate que
un certain nombre de craintes
s'expriment notamment chez chez certains
garçons lorsqu'ils doutent de leur
capacité ou de leur volonté à tenir ce
rôle de performance ou de domination et
qu'ils se demandent si du coup ils sont
normaux et s'ils sont de vrais garçons
dont on a entendu ce genre de choses la
deuxième répercussions sociales c'est
évidemment une confortation des
stéréotypes des identités de genre et
des rôles sexuels il s'agit là d'une
représentation qui est d'un univers qui
est très hétéro norme et où les hommes
sont à l'initiative et les femmes
réceptive et où l'hypersexualisation et
l'objectivation des filles et des femmes
est la norme enfin on a bien sûr des
répercussions sur l'idée que se font les
jeunes de la notion de consentement en
très bref la pornographie réactive à
l'infini de vieil adage que le nom n'est
pas toujours à prendre en compte pas
forcément à respecter et que les rares
limites qui sont exprimées par les
personnages féminins ou féminisé ne sont
pas respectées la scénarisation du viol
est d'ailleurs un argument commercial
qui est souvent mis en avant ce
message-là peut très vite être
intériorisée par les jeunes enfin on a
bien sûr des répercussions
psychologiques notamment chez les très
jeunes chez certains adolescents qui
sont déjà fragiles et ses répercussions
se traduisent par des rennais licence
sexuelle les images qui reviennent en
boucle qui provoque des cauchemars des
angoisses des états de panique des peur
d'être agressés également et puis bien
sûr une habituation à la violence
psychologique et sexuelle il y à des
études de médecins à qui
démontre toutes ses répercussions 1 chez
les jeunes très rapidement aussi
mentionné les répercussions médical un
certain nombre de médecins haweij sur la
question de l'accoutumance à la
pornographie chez les jeunes certains
dont serge stoléru dont je vous invite à
aller consulter les travaux médecins
psychiatres décrivent très bien ce
phénomène et ce besoin que vont avoir
les jeunes de regarder de plus en plus
de vidéos et les vidéos de plus en plus
violente pour pouvoir retrouver l'effet
premier lors de la première exposition à
la pornographie alors devant de telles
conséquences qui mériterait vraiment
d'être développé beaucoup plus il est
vraiment urgent d'agir parce que les
quelques heures de prévention que
certains jeunes peuvent bénéficier de
notre part ou de la part d'autres
associations ne pèse vraiment pas lourd
face à la manière dont cette industrie
s'est rendue si aisément accessible aux
enfants et aux adolescents et je pense
qu'il faut aller maintenant beaucoup
plus loin que de travailler sur
simplement en limiter l'accès et je vous
remercie
il a écouté merci pour ces propos très
éclairant est très inquiétant j'ai
immédiatement passé la parole
aux intervenantes suivante je laisse
donc la parole à céline piqué et le
labour est d'osez le féminisme est
bienvenue
voilà
non mais vous vous organisez quand vous
le souhaitez
avec l'air tout à fait à part moi
j'avais inversée dans l'autre sens on
m'avait prévenu que d'une seule
inversion mais si vous souhaitez
inversée à nouveau notre problème
[Musique]
eh bien écoutez on va passer la parole
aux effrontée et donc je vous souhaite
la bienvenue madame et je vous cède
immédiatement la parole
[Musique]
excusez moi je croyais qu'il était
utilisé à pied
on nous sommes une association féministe
et lgbt et nous sommes abolitionniste du
système prostitueur depuis 2012 dans
lequel nous incluons l'apprendre la
pornographie je vais pas revenir donc
sur ce qui a été dit en fait moi je les
surtout insisté sur la question vraiment
de la violence inouïe de la pornographie
men stream d'aujourd'hui en fait donc si
vous me permettez je vais avoir un
moment donné l'occasion en fait de dire
les choses comme elles sont et ça ça
inclut des mots crus j'espère que ça ça
gênera pas des mots assez cru en fait
assez explicite parce qu'en fait il
s'agit en fait de montrer tout
simplement les contenus tels qu'ils sont
les synopsis sur internet et du coup je
vais vous dévoiler un petit peu ça parce
que je ne sais pas forcément si vous
êtes au fait j'ai commandé juste
approcher un tout petit peu plus d'une
autre micro de deux pour que ceux qui
sont en visio puisse vous bien sûr
également clairement pas de problème
mais du coup on est vraiment au dessus
sur des actes de torture de violence
trésor inouïe d'une recherche de
dezellus déshumanisation et pas du tout
de liberté sexuelle en fait comme le
prétendent donc les défenseurs de cette
industrie qui vont même jusqu'à produire
des films en fait qui vont être
diffusées par des médias connus où on va
avoir des actrices des acteurs qui vont
dire que c'est formidable
un petit peu comme si le lobby du tabac
en gros disait que fumer n'est pas
mauvais pour la santé par exemple donc
en fait il faut savoir que 80 % des
scènes de pornographie contiennent de la
violence explicite et le porno en fait
dit trash qu'il ya quelques dizaines
d'années en fête est devenue le porno
main stream d'aujourd'hui les contenus
en fait les plus violents sont même les
plus regardées donc c'est vider ces
vidéos qui figure dans l'est ce qu'on
appelle étape critique dont les vraiment
les vidéos les plus vues qui vont
contenir des pratiques extrêmement
violente
que je vais devoir vous détailler un
petit peu pour vous faciliter par
exemple ce qui est de le plus demandé ça
va être la pratique du jogging qui va
être l'étouffement en fait avec le pénis
lors d'une fellation kipawa l'est qui
peut aller jusqu aux vomissements en
fait de la femme victime
quand on parle également de double
pénétration de triple pénétration il
s'agit vraiment et là encore excusez-moi
de la crudité des ternes mais il s'agit
vraiment de tri bleus pénétration dans
un même orifices donc parfois on imagine
que c'est pas possible mais c'est le cas
et c'est vraiment pour nous de la
torture et de la barbarie à pure et
simple
on va avoir des étranglements on va voir
ce qu'on appelle le but cac et donc
c'est une pratique qui s'est développée
d'ailleurs le le procès dont on va
parler céline ensuite étape les procès
du french bouquet qu puisque le
producteur pascal op s'est fait
connaître là dessus il s'agit en fait
d'une cinquantaine d'hommes qui vont
faire subir des fellations et jacques
hui ensuite sur le visage d'une actrice
qui peut même en subir des des brûlures
donc pour vous dire à quel point ces
c'est vraiment grave et violent
vous allez avoir des femmes enceinte de
huit mois donc un abus de faiblesse vous
allez avoir un certain nombre de
catégories aussi en fait qu'ils font
vraiment
par exemple le bdsm vous allez avoir des
femmes qui vont hurler de douleur donc
c'est vraiment pas simuler en fait c'est
ça qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
c'est pas du cinéma c'est pas de la
simulation une femme qui pleure qui
parfois saigne on ne peut pas considérer
que c'est que ces fins si vous voulez
que c'est stimuler et quiconque en fait
en serez témoin dans l'espace public ne
pourrait pas tolérer ce genre de
violences est en fait quand c'est la
pornographie quelque part personne ne
veut le questionner en fait et c'est ça
qui nous qui nous qui nous semble plus
possible donc en fait on est même sur
des infractions à caractériser qui vont
être
du racisme de la misogynie de la
pédocriminalité de la lesbophobie d
incitation à la haine raciale
dont j'avais un petit peu vous détailler
les catégories qui existent pour que
vous puissiez vraiment visualiser
qu'elle est en fait la demande des
consommateurs de porno puisque ces
catégories sont vraiment là pour
répondre à cette demande elles sont pas
là par hasard évidemment donc vous allez
avoir la catégorie fantasme familiale
donc en fait je vais vous donner pour
ces catégories les mots clés qui
reviennent ce sont des choses on trouve
sur des sites internet qui normalement
de par son contenu devrait être fermé en
fait parce que ce sont des contenus en
fait qu'ils sont tout simplement
illégaux par exemple le fantasme
femelles et familial ça va être donc en
anglais d'asie fuck christine d'automne
donc en plus on a l'aspect
pédocriminalité lié au fait qu'on parle
d'une jeune fille mineure est en plus un
cestus elle incestueux donc incitation à
des actes incestueux
donc s'il ya toute une catégorie tine
qui est vraiment très très regardé donc
ça on va vraiment être sûr du fantasme
pédocriminels parce qu'on va avoir des
jeux des actrices parfois adultes mais
pas toujours qu'ils vont être habillées
en écolières avec des couettes avec des
jupettes donc on est vraiment sur un
stéréotype d'enfants en fait alors que
la loi incrimine le fait de représenter
des images d'enfants ou d'ados érotisée
même sous forme de dessin ça aussi c'est
le savoir pour pour essayer de
comprendre comment c'est possible que
ces représentations du coup existe sous
la forme en fait cinématographique entre
guillemets dans des catégories vraiment
spécifique vous allez avoir aussi tout
le côté raciste alors là qui est
vraiment extrêmement présents dont vous
avez une catégorie interracial ont par
exemple vous allez voir des hommes noirs
animalisés qu'on va mettre en scène avec
une frêle jeune femme blonde qui va être
le stéréotype un petit peu
l'archétype aryenne donc avec le côté il
viole nos femmes donc il ya vraiment
cette espèce de d'imaginaire raciste qui
est très très présent vous allez avoir
la catégorie black avec donc il ya des
des termes des demandes et des mots clés
qui sont trop vagues sans vraiment les
synopsis des vidéos pour inciter les
gens à cliquer sur les vidéos en
question et même vous avez des gens qui
vont faire des recherches de ces mots
clés pour trouver les vidéos parce que
ces mots clés sont connus donc au fur et
à mesure les gens vont tout simplement
les rechercher pour trouver ce qu'ils
veulent donc pour les catégorique black
vous allez trouver des choses
comme monsters inc en fait il ya
toujours tous les stéréotypes coloniaux
et raciste qui vont être perpétuée par
ces catégories où on va avoir en fait
des acteurs et actrices qui vont être
sélectionnées pour correspondre rester à
ces stéréotypes racistes par exemple
gros sexe pour les hommes grosses fesses
pour les femmes
on va voir ses schémas raciste et ses
êtres humains qui vont être animalisés
dont c'est tout simplement aussi que de
enfin ans a rejoint l'appel à la haine
tout simplement se sont destinés aux 6
vraiment sans ambivalence c'est vraiment
de l'appel à la haine vous allez avoir
des choses comme jeune beurette souillé
par excusez moi de la crudité des ternes
mais par des dit stone blanc
vous allez avoir toute une des
catégories raciales différentes donc
asiatique avec de stéréotypes de
l'asiatique soumises bourret avec le
stéréotype d'une de la brette [__] qui
doit être souillés par des hommes blancs
[Musique]
je vais pas toujours où tout vous
décrire mais c'est vrai c'est tout et
dans le monde mais en fait tout ce que
vous trouvez c'est vraiment quand vous
cherchez des vidéos sur internet vous ne
tombez que là dessus c'est à dire que
c'est pas anodin c'est pas marginal
c'est vraiment la grande majorité des
contenus qu'ils sont sûrs parce que
c'est ça que vers ça que recherchent les
gens et en fait on fleith chez les gens
les plus bas instincts qui ne peuvent
pas s'exprimer par ailleurs dans la
société parce que tout s'est essayée
représentation raciste en fait sont
encadrés par la liberté d'expression
normalement ne ne devrait pas pouvoir
s'exprimer c'est à dire que dans même
quand on parle de couverts du cinéma si
c'était dans n'importe quel autre
support n'importe quel autre film en
fait ça serait censurée ça serait
interdite est en fait dans le cadre de
la pornographie il ya cette espèce de
zone de non droit où d'un coup on peut
un peu exprimé les stéréotypes racistes
qui vont aller flatter les crée même des
fantasmes chez les gens des fantasmes de
sexiste et raciste
vous allez avoir des catégories viole
également avec des mots clés qui sont
encore une fois sans ambivalence vous
allez avoir surprise annales sur price
fuck prise par surprise
facialement voulu etc etc
et là c'est vraiment aussi les
incitation à commettre des crimes c'est
à dire que vraiment tout ça en fait si
vous le passé au crible du code pénal
chaque catégorie correspond à une
infraction en fait spécifique qui va
être incitation à commettre des crimes
qui va être incitation à la haine
raciale qui va être incitation à
l'inceste soit la pédocriminalité
vous avez des catégories enlèvement et
séquestration avec des mots clés comme
enlèvement kidnapping
des catégories humiliation aussi avec
des insultes sexistes
les mots clés comme couleur elle pleure
douleur crachats
qui sont des choses que les femmes
subissent pour de vrai c'est vraiment
encore une fois c'est pas quelque chose
de faim quand là quand la femme pleure
elle pleure vraiment et c'est ce qui va
être recherchée par les gens qui vont
consommer ce type de vidéos donc ça
aussi ça doit est vraiment nous
interpeller et nous et nous comment dire
cc c'est pas normal en fait que con con
flat dans la société
cette recherche chez des zones d'une
déshumanisation et d'une
comment dire d'un pouvoir en fait exercé
avec un avilissement des femmes par la
douleur les pleurs
etc la torture vous allez avoir une
catégorie prostitution donc là il ya
institutions incitation à la
prostitution et vous allez avoir une
même catégorie esclaves avec même
carrément en fait des mises en commande
iran en scénario de 2,2 d'esclaves noirs
habillés comme tels qu'ils appellent un
homme blanc mettre sur un décor de
plantation donc il ya vraiment une
reproduction de scènes historiques qui
se sont vraiment à produite
vous allez avoir d'aidé voilà des mots
clés comme esclaves sexuelles soumises
esclaves et c
est également dans l'est je parlais tout
à l'heure les pratiques vous avez aussi
dans la catégorie donc de l'humiliation
et de la douleur vous avez le prolapsus
le prolapsus génitales en fait c'est une
pathologie féminine à la base
il s'agit en fait de la descente dans le
vagin des différents organes qui repose
sur le plancher le plancher pelvien donc
l'utérus la vessie ou le rectum et là
vous allez avoir des catégories où vous
allez provoquer dans une scène de film
pornographique ce pro lapsus qui va être
visuellement
de l'extérieur mais ça va être visible
en avec des lésions
à redon
avec des lésions anales du sang fin des
des choses vraiment visible de
l'extérieur qu'on n'a pas besoin de
faire venir un médecin pour pour voir ce
qui se passe quoi
et en fait tout ça donc c'est du viol et
érotiser c'est la violence sexuelle
érotisée est ce qu il faut savoir aussi
c'est que tout ça en fait shari
énormément d'argent
sur le jeu je sais pas si j'en piètre
pas sur ce que tu dis céline d'accord
non en fait il faut savoir qui est à 136
milliards de vidéos qui sont visionnées
par an et qu'en fait et 35 vidéo 35% des
vidéos sur internet sans de la
pornographie les revenus du porno
s'élève à 140 milliards de dollars par
an et en fait ça pour les etats unis
c'est 17 milliards et c'est plus que
netflix et la nba réunis est en fait qu
il faut aussi se poser ces questions-là
c'est à dire qu'est ce que cette
industrie pèse dans l'économie réelle et
donc quels sont les intérêts colossaux
économiques qui sont derrière et qui
évidemment entrant en résonance et en
collision avec le la société patriarcale
et donc
qui va également flatter tous les plus
beaux instants patriarcaux aura 6 et ces
mêmes pédocriminels pour faire cette
quantité colossale d'argent et en fait
nous tous un gros tout ce combat avec
avec les lois dans la sphère publique
on a l'impression d'un coup c'est
autorisé dans la pornographie parce que
ça serait de l'ordre du privé alors qu
en fait la division sphère publique et
sphère privée normalement on pensait
l'avoir dépassée puisque par exemple
viol conjugal est condamné la violence
domestique est condamné et d'un coup
dans la pornographie ça redevient de
l'ordre de l'intimé de la sexualité donc
tout ça ce sont évidemment des des
façons de voile et ce qui s'appelle en
fait de la torture de la violences des
viols de la barbarie et en fait ça sert
vraiment l'intérêt d'une industrie qui
génère des profits absolument colossaux
et et de la même manière les l'effet
nice le répète depuis longtemps que
privés comme intimes sont politiques et
en fait ce que des violences sexuelles
et physiques se déroule dans l'espace
public ou dans la sphère pris le
domestique ça ne change rien à leur
caractère illégal en fait et en fait ils
devront être demain il doit en être de
même lorsque ces violences se déroulent
derrière une caméra sous le maquillage
sémantique de pornographie
donc non on considère que ça peut pas
voilà être considérée comme une offre
d'emploi comme une autre bah d'imposer
de mai des multiples fellation
simultanée d'imposer des strangulation
des attouchements des lésions anales
des vomissements et c'est tout ce que je
vous ai décrit juste avant
et d'autant que maintenant on a vraiment
des témoignages la presse
montre ce qu'on savait déjà avant parce
que si vous voulez ces vidéos elles sont
quand même alors tout le monde ne
visionne pas de vidéo de porno mais ce
sont des tout ça c'est très très cd
vidéos qui font qu'ils sont vues par des
millions des milliards de dhs éminente
personnes en fait donc quelque part
c'était quelque chose qu'on a c'est un
peu quelque chose qu'on a sous nos yeux
et qu'on ne voit pas il faut vraiment
maintenant en fait pour nous il est plus
possible de fermer les yeux devant ce
système criminel bac l industrie
phonographique et en fait on pense que
les pouvoirs publics ne devraient plus
tolérer cette zone en fait de non droit
ou en fait tout ce qui est inacceptable
au-dehors devient d'un coup toléré entre
les murs de cette industrie donc voilà
je vous ai un peu d'écrits c'est
synopsis vraiment d'une profonde
misogynie également lesbophobes avec des
filles l'alcool des vidéos de femmes
lesbiennes ou à la faim intervient
l'homme qui ferait en fait pouvoir les
remettre sur le droit chemin entre
guillemets donc il ya vraiment un panel
incroyable de d'incitation à la haine
contre des catégories minorisées
et qui sans vraiment qualifiable
pénalement qui sont dix ans qui sont des
contenus qui ceux qui sont en fait de
fait illégaux quoi voilà je vais en
rester là je pense que j'ai est basse et
mon temps de parole écoutée merci
beaucoup pour avoir porté la parole des
effrontées ses propos extrêmement clair
et d'une violence incroyable et comme le
disait la rapporteure laurence rossignol
tout à l'heure on n'avait pas imaginé
certains des témoignages que vous vous
avez évoqué ce matin donc c'est vrai que
c'est des témoignages très difficiles et
on s'aperçoit qu'on a réussi à voter une
loi anti prostitutionnel mais que
finalement la
constitution
à trouver un autre chemin finalement
puisque tous les travers reproché à la
prostitution se retrouve dans la
pornographie et toute la violence
imposée essentiellement aux femmes et
les situations dégradantes son
se retrouve dans la pornographie merci
pour vos mots même si ce matin de bonne
heure enfin le bonheur pas forcément
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez violent
et on avait on se doute que nous ne
sommes qu'au début de ce travail avec
des rapporteurs et que ça va pas aller
en s'arrangeant donc je vais
immédiatement cédé la parole à à céline
pic et elsa labouret pour osez le
féminisme
cette fois ci on a perturbé lors mais
c'est bien votre tour désormais à vous
mesdames
merci beaucoup de vos présentations à
toutes les trois je vais essayer de
prendre la suite après a effectivement
ces descriptions puisque sordide morbide
et je vais vous parler un petit peu
l'aspect juridique et l'aspect des
procès qui sont aujourd'hui en cours
avant de parler de l' affaire qui nous
concerne sur lequel nos trois
associations sont parties civiles je
vais faire un petit détour par les états
unis parce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france il se passe
également aux états unis il ya un mythe
ou de la pornographie aujourd'hui qui
est extrêmement puissant l'afer a
commencé en décembre 2020 avec la sphère
pornhub où il y à un article dans le new
york times que je vous incite à aller
voir qui s'appelle children of pornhub
et qui démontre que en fait n'importe
qui peut plaider des vidéos sur pornhub
sans aucun contrôle d'identité donc
n'importe qui peut claude et en
particulier des vidéos de viol et
l'article du new york times est le fruit
d'une longue enquête montre qu'une
enfant de 14 ans qui avait été enlevé
séquestré et victime d'un viol collectif
avait vu son violent upload est sûre
pornhub elle n'est pas seulement il y a
énormément au delà de l'aspect violence
des tournages soi-disant cinéma
cinématographique il ya énormément de ce
qu'on appelle du revenge porte c'est à
dire des vrais vidéo de viols d'enfants
des vraies vidéos de viols de femmes sur
bornes ça va pas le micro
pardon pardon pardon excusez moi il a
baissé au
ya pas de problème tout de suite locaux
vides donc sur cet article du new york
times il démontre également que pendant
aucun système de retrait des vidéos et
ses enfants qui avaient vu les vidéos de
leurs propres viol ont pesé sur le site
n'arrivait pas à faire retirer les
vidéos de portneuf quand cette enquête
est sortie ça a été la panique aux états
unis et mastercard et visa card voyons
bien qu'ils étaient mouillés avec une
gigantesque a fait affaire de trafic
sexuel et de diffusion de vidéos
d'enfants a coupé l'accès aux sites
internets donc coupé et robinet d'argent
et l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre
dans cette industrie porno criminelle
est donc derrière ça
pornhub a supprimé 10 millions parmi les
13 millions qui étaient en ligne en
disant que 10 millions il n'y avait
aucune vérification aucune aucun
contrôle d'identité de la personne qui
le plot dès aujourd'hui reste encore 3
millions mais il n'y a aucune
vérification
bien sûr du du pseudo consentement que
pourrait avoir donné les femmes qui sont
dans ces vidéos et nous avons encore des
vidéos de viols collectifs qui sont sur
cette plateforme pour finir malgré le
retrait des 10 millions de vidéos sur
les treize
guilde hines alors elle a été a déjà
cité mais je me permets de citer ghaidan
ça fait trente ans qu'elle travaille sur
ce sujet c'est une chercheuse aux états
unis à boston qui a écrit un livre
majeur qui s'appelle pas un monde qui
dit ça depuis des années des années en
fait est que nous on relaie depuis là
c'est assez longtemps et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle est entendue aux
états unis avaient quand même fait le
décompte que malgré le retrait de 10
millions sur les 13 millions
problématique il restait encore
149 1840 vidéo avec le hashtag tine donc
apologie la pédocriminalité il y avait
encore 71 1608 vidéo danse est donc les
vidéos dans 16 sur cc c'est toujours la
même chose c'est firefox tin oo bien
d'halifax chistine et donc on a des
scénarios les scénarios d'inceste donc
j'ai une pensée aujourd'hui pour la
civis qui travaille aujourd'hui sur la
lutte contre l'inceste et on ne peut pas
imaginer lutter contre l'inceste si on
perd mais que ces vidéos qui font
l'apologie de l'inceste soit en ligne 71
milles 608 il faut savoir également que
ce type de vidéo est utilisée par les
violeurs pédocriminels je pense par
exemple à la faire justice pour julie ou
les pompiers en tout cas que accuse
julie de violent mettaient
systématiquement des vidéos de viol
collectif quand ils voulaient commettre
des viols à plusieurs sur cet enfant de
13 ans c'est aussi le cas et on espère
avoir un certain nombre d'études ce
serait bien qu'on ait des études là
dessus sur la façon dont les pères
incestueux utilisent ces vidéos pour
commettre des viols qui s'appelle le
grooming et ça permet de mettre en
confiance et de sidérer l'enfant avant
de commettre un viol pédocriminels donc
le problème c'est que ces 71 1608 vidéo
sur pornhub qui sont l'apologie de la
pédocriminalité sont illégales sont
illégales parce que c'est l'apologie
d'un crime et donc de la même façon
qu'on peut poursuivre eric zemmour pour
apologie de la haine raciale on devrait
pouvoir poursuivre corner pour apologie
de la pédocriminalité apple apologie de
l'inceste et ensuite dans les catégories
qui reste on a bien suffocation
étranglement
étouffement
évanouissements
et bien sûr le fameux pro l'aps on voit
je pense que là on peut parler
effectivement de scènes de torture on
voit littéralement les entrailles de la
femme violentée tout ça relève pas du
tout du tout du cinéma donc je pense que
s'il y avait un seul message qu'on
voudrait faire passer aujourd'hui c'est
que ce n'est pas du cinéma je pense
qu'il faudrait même à arrêter d'appeler
ça acteurs et actrices les violences
sont réels c'est ça qui fait la
différence entre le cinéma et la la
violence c'est que dans le cinéma quand
il ya un meurtre quand il ya un coup ça
a été dit par claire quidet les
violences sont simulés là ce sont des
vraies violences et il m'a fallu à peu
près deux secondes et demi pour trouver
une vidéo intitulée ado enceinte de huit
mois violet brutalement par vingt hommes
et on avait une adolescente thaïlandaise
vraisemblablement à bangkok enceinte
effectivement de huit mois qui avait
l'apparence d'une enfant de 15 ans donc
on en est là aujourd'hui ça c'est en
accès libre sur pornhub pour tous vos
enfants adultes ou enfants je pense que
c'est la même chose moi j'en ai
littéralement des cauchemars parce que
j'ai passé quelques heures
ça se trouve extrêmement extrêmement
facilement sur port loeb alors
maintenant revenons aucun français donc
aux états unis pour pour info il ya une
multitude de class action qui sont
lancés de class action avec des
centaines de victimes dans particulier
d'enfants dont les viols ont été
applaudis sur portable il y a aussi des
actions pour trafic sexuel contre x
vidéo qui est une autre grande plate
forme et donc les procès vont éclater
dans tous les sens et my geek la
maison-mère de pornhub est sur la
sellette et a été a fait l'objet d'une
d'une commission parlementaire au canada
qui sert enfin saisi de cette question
là et donc les choses sont en train de
bouger très très vite aux états unis là
dessus et on espère qu'enfin et procès
pour en mettre des mots sur la réalité
aujourd'hui de la pornographie un
système de violence et proxénétisme
organisé à l'échelle industrielle qui
fait l'apologie de la haine des femmes
l'apologie du racisme alors maintenant
je vais vous parler du cas français et
je vous ai amené une petite photo je
pense que c'est important quand même de
savoir de quoi on parle pas je vous
présente pascal op pascal au pays il est
aujourd'hui en prison mise en examen
pour viols proxénétisme aggravé et
traite des êtres humains et sur la photo
je ne sais pas si vous voyez la photo
mais vous avez vous êtes dans un hangar
voilà vous êtes dans un langage et puis
là il ya une palette et autour de la
palette est à environ 80 hommes cagoulés
et 80 hommes cagoulés vont passer sur la
femme qui va être mise sur cette palette
ensuite une fois que ils seront tous
passés dessus ils vont tous éjaculer en
même temps ce qui va vraisemblablement
lui occasionner des brûlures avancé
c'est ce que rappelle en particulier
robin d'angelo qui a écrit un livre
extrêmement parlant sur le sujet qui est
sorti en 2018 robin d'angelo a infiltré
le milieu du porno pendant 18 mois il
s'est fait passer pour un caméraman et
il a été sur les sites de tournage il a
assisté à une scène de but qu'à quai il
a eu envie de vomir et on peut dire que
ce type de scène c'est un acte de
torture et de barbarie ça se passait à
paris xiiie à peu près à 500 m d'ici
comment ils recrutent et les gars il
envoyait un twitter le mercredi en
disant venez vous videz les couilles
dans une grosse [__] gratuit venez
avec une cagoule donc lui c'est un
producteur de jackie et michel jacquet
michel ce n'est pas du port amateurs
c'est du proxénétisme aggravé et en
particulier rondins angelo dans une
vidéo qui est sorti sur combiné en 2020
a diffusé l'enregistrement de michel
piron président et directeur général de
jackie et michel qui explique à une
personne que s'il y aura même des filles
il libéra de la thune mais bon l on
mettra pas sur la facture proxénétisme
parce que bon le proxénétisme c'est
interdit en france donc bien entendu
l'intégralité de la chaîne c'est ce
qu'ils font du producteur aux diffuseurs
on sait très bien qu'il y à des
techniques pour piéger manipuler
recruter ces femmes et les amener sur
les tournages c'est ce que raconte la
quête du monde je vous invite
incroyablement écrire à lire cette
enquête qui donne un certain nombre
d'éléments sur le procès de l'industrie
porno criminels qui va avoir lieu on a
aujourd'hui 50 femmes victimes quatre
producteurs mise en examen et quatre
acteurs mise en examen pour viols
proxénétisme aggravé et traite des êtres
humains et bien sûr blanchiment de
fraude fiscale etc etc puisque la
plupart des plateformes comme des
diffuseurs utilisent largement des
paradis fiscaux pour ne pas payer bien
sûr un centime de taxes dans ce pays par
rapport au caractère légal ou pas légal
et ses dents judy le lasso chaque mois
10 du mois d'immersion journalistique ya
jamais de contrats travail n'y a pas de
contrat de travail c'est pas un travail
la pornographie il n'y a pas de contrat
elle signe donc c'est simple elles sont
payées environ 200 euros pour une scène
après avoir été rabattu par un proxénète
et ensuite à la fin de la scène on leur
fait signer une sorte de droit animal
dont elles ont même pas une copie et
elle rentre chez elle on leur a promis
que la vidéo serait diffusée uniquement
sur un petit site confidentiel au canada
et elle se retrouve sur toutes les
plateformes trois jours plus tard
détruites devoir bien sûr certaines avec
leur vrai nom d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
certaines avec leurs vrais noms les
vidéos des tournages sur lesquelles
elles ont été piégées
quoi dire de plus par rapport à un
porno
je pense que l' enquête du monde si vous
l'avez lu lé elle est implacable et il y
a aussi également en particulier chez
jackie et michel un système d'extras
d'extorsion de fond c'est à dire qu'une
fois que la vidéo a été applaudi il
extorque que les femmes en leur
demandant de 3000 à 5000 euros pour
faire retirer les vidéos ce retrait des
vidéos n'est pas effectif c'est à dire
que en fait si éventuellement la vidéo
est retirée sur jackie et michel étant
donné que sur les grandes plateformes
type aït vidéo hooper loeb personne
personne ne vérifie qu'ils upload ces
vidéos n'importe quel particulier peut
récupérer une vidéo sur dorcel ou sur
jackie et michel et la réole claude et
sur une plateforme comme x vidéo
n'importe qui peut claude est une vidéo
de viols sur ses plateformes aujourd'hui
c'est ça la réalité de la pornographie
donc alors maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors moi je vous dis je vais vous
dire une façon très simple enfin mon
sentiment qui est très simple mon
sentiment qui est très simple c'est que
il faut simplement
arrêter de considérer que c'est du
cinéma ce n'est pas du cinéma à partir
du moment où les scènes ne sont pas
simuler et les scènes de violence ne
sont pas simuler et à ce moment là on
passe au crible ce qu'est réellement la
pornographie au regard du code pénal et
qu'est ce que dit le code pénal c'est
que c'est de la prostitution filmé et
donc les diffuseurs et les producteurs
selon la définition alors je vous
rappelle quand même la définition légale
du proxénétisme la définition légale du
proxénétisme c'est tirer profit de la
prostitution d'autrui et donc ça fait
c'est légalement parlant si on analyse
uniquement les textes de loi aujourd'hui
la pornographie et du proxénétisme alors
comment on en est arrivé là et comment
ça se fait que cette industrie a pignon
sur rue et pourquoi on ne fait rien
comme sais rien parce que il ya encore
un certain nombre de mythes qui dirait
que c'est un travail que c'est du cinéma
et c'est extrêmement problématique qu'on
maintienne smith et qu'on peut en tout
cas nous on demande d'associations
féministes c'est que le procès ait lieu
et qu'on voit les techniques de
recrutement qui sont exactement les
mêmes que les techniques de recrutement
dans la prostitution
piégée et tu les femmes on voit
d'ailleurs dans l' enquête du monde
derrière qu'il ya un viol
prostitutionnel au départ pour casser
les femmes victimes avant de les livrer
aux
producteurs de pornographie et puis
l'ensemble de la chaîne est
complètement au clair sur ce qui est en
train de se passer sur ses tournages et
la façon dont à ces violences sont
commises alors ensuite pour un point de
vue juridique donc il ya plusieurs
choses il ya les vidéos les vidéos par
rapport au synopsis ce qu'on a dit
apologie de crime c'est puni par la loi
après logique pédocriminalité apologie
d'inceste apologie de la haine raciale
apologie la lesbophobie tout ça c'est de
l'incitation à commettre des crimes cd
apologie de crime c'est puni enfin on
peut poursuivre aujourd'hui les
plateformes pour le caractère illégal de
ces vidéos deuxièmement la pornographie
c'est la prostitution film et donc on
demande à ce que la loi soit appliquée
concernant en particulier la loi sur le
proxénétisme et enfin je voudrais vous
dire que tout ceci est extrêmement clair
enfin on a régressé ces dernières années
en voulant nous faire croire que c'était
du cinéma et que c'était cool et c'est
comme ça que les jeunes allaient
s'éduquer à la sexualité je vais vous
lire une résolution
sur la pornographie qui date de
1993 fait au parlement européen en fait
il ya beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites et faites sur la pornographie en
particulier donc on est en
1993 je vous lis quatre lignes convaincu
que la pornographie constitue une
pratique systématique d'exploitation et
de subordination fondée sur le sexe qui
portent préjudice aux femmes dans une
mesure disproportionnée qu'elle
contribue à l'inégalité entre les sexes
et accentue le déséquilibre des forces
dans la société l'assujettissement des
femmes et la domination des hommes
vendre 17 décembre 1993 position du
parlement européen
donc en fait on a un certain nombre de
textes on a bien sûr toutes nos
dispositifs légaux sur la prostitution
on a un certain nombre de résolutions au
niveau du parlement européen qui ont
toujours dit que la pornographie étais
tu une violence fait contre les femmes
et maintenant ce qu on demande
simplement c'est que la pornographie
cesse d'être cette zone de non droit et
que les lois actuelles s'applique comme
elles peuvent s'appliquer sur la
prostitution et sur le proxénétisme
actuellement quand on parle de réseaux
de traite et dernier ni points et
ensuite je vais passer la parole à elsa
je vais vous parler un petit peu du csa
alors déjà j'aimerais remercier le sénat
parce que le sénat le 23 juillet 2020
grâce à un amendement ça a été dit de
marie mercier à la loi sur les violences
conjugales a été ajouté un
la possibilité pour le csa de poursuivre
les sites puisque depuis plus de vingt
ans il y à une loi qui n'est pas acquis
n'est pas respectée en fait là faut
savoir que la plupart des sites sont
souvent dans l'illégalité la plus totale
un retrait de refus des vidéos et
évasion fiscale
retrait enfin donc les injonctions à
respecter la loi concernant l'âge des
mineurs il sent entre nous il s'en fiche
et donc le csa donc depuis 20 ans existe
une loi qui interdit l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie parce que
l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie est complètement
incompatible aujourd'hui avec l'objectif
d'une éducation sexuelle qui
impliquerait l'éducation consentement
l'éducation à la dezir et aux rencontres
entre deux personnes qui désirent un
acte sexuel on est vraiment sûr dans la
pornographie sur l'érotisation de la
violence et donc pour le csa donc cette
fois n'était pas appliquée depuis 20 ans
et maintenant le csa a pour mandat de
bloquer les sites qui refusent de
vérifier l'âge alors effectivement cinq
sites ont été mises en demeure le 13
décembre
la devait il avait quinze jours pour
pour s'exécuter alors les sites s'en
foutent complètement excusez moi du
terme x vidéo par exemple qui est
l'autre grande plateforme comme pornhub
hammami un tuto pour avec un vpn contrer
toute tentative de blocage des sites
donc ils n'ont aucune intention de
collaborer sur quoi que ce soit une
vidéo par exemple et est basée en
république tchèque leur pdg c'est les
frères pas causé deux frères français
qui habitent en france d'ailleurs
tranquillement mais leur argent et entre
chéquier paradis fiscaux et les frères
pas qu on me sur leur site un mode
d'emploi pour contourner un éventuel
blocage du csa d'accord donc on en est
là donc j'espère que ça va avoir de la
détermination pour faire respecter au
moins à minima cette première
interdiction d'exposition aux mineurs et
osez le féminisme a fait 7 alors le csa
avait fait avait été saisie par des
associations de protection de l'enfance
sur huit sites cinq ont été mises en
demeure aux et féminisme au mois de
décembre a fait une saisie du csa sur
118 sites c'est à dire à peu près
l'intégralité des sites pornos
accessible en france au nom de 118 et
nous avons saisi le csa pour leur
demander également de faire appliquer la
loi et de mettre un contrôle d'âge sur
les mineurs de façon urgente et de
réagir et simplement de ils ont la
possibilité aujourd'hui de saisir la
justice est d'ordre de faire de
d'ordonner le blocage des sites qui ne
mettrait pas en place des contrôles
d'âge pour ne pas exposer les enfants à
ces scènes de torture et c'est une
excellente transition vers elsa qui va
vous parler de l'impact sur la
pornographie sur la sexualité des jeunes
et sur nos sexualités aussi à nos
bons jours
alors je complétais un peu ce qu'a dit
ce que le mouvement jean et je suis on
n'a pas toujours les jeunes je parviens
sur la violence va qui a été décrite
mais ça paraît peut-être assez intuitif
deux tiers à quel point ça peut
influencer les jeunes mais je vais vous
donner
quelques détails des quelques exemples
alors osez féminisme a travaillé
beaucoup cette année sur une question la
question des jeunes et de la sexualité
puisqu'on a sorti un livre à destination
des jeunes qui est le petit guide pour
une sexualité féministe et épanouie et
dont l'un des objectifs était de
proposer autre chose que la pornographie
comme ça a été dit la pornographie est
vraiment l' inverse l'exact opposé d'une
sexualité saine
malheureusement c'est aujourd'hui
extrêmement facile d'en trouver comme ça
a été dit déjà donc pour les jeunes
c'est encore une introduction très très
facilement accessible et la sexualité
est souvent la première chose que les
enfants voient et découvre sur la
sexualité en particulier les garçons à
qui peut-être les parents vont parler un
peu moins de sexualité puisqu'on en
parle beaucoup au chili notamment pour
prévenir prévenir des grossesses non
désirées mais les gars ont bénéficié un
peu moins de ça quant à la l'éducation
sexuelle dans les écoles elle est pas
encore assez systématique et surtout
elle n'est pas assez complète sur
l'essai comment construire une sexualité
saine et respectueuse
donc pour les garçons introduction la
pornographie représente aussi un rite de
masculinité à un rite de passage à l'âge
adulte encore là quelques jours une amie
militante a parlé d'un petit garçon
qu'elle connaît qui disait ah oui ce
soir tu sais je rentre chez moi jackie
et michel tu sais le garçon avait 11 ans
et les adultes autour de lui est
complètement normalisée banaliser tout
ça avec ce qu'on sait maintenant de
jackie et michel un garçon de 11 ans qui
regardent ça ne ce ne devrait pas être
banalisé on devrait s'en inquiéter très
très fort
donc une étude a été faite en 2017 par
l'ifop sur les comporte le mot la
consommation de pornographie chez les ad
l'adolescent et son influence sur leur
comportement sexuel
donc aujourd'hui deux tiers des garçons
de 15 à 17 ans ont déjà consulté des
sites pornographiques et un tiers des
filles donc pour les deux c6 frais en
hausse très forte et c'est encore le
chiffre de 2010 est donc on peut être
sûr qu'ils aient encore une augmentation
aujourd'hui l'âge du premier l'âge moyen
du premier visionnage se situe entre 12
et 14 ans
donc parfois encore un plus jeune encore
avant le début de la puberté est plus
jeune que peut-être les premières
conversations qu'on peut avoir avec les
enfants sur la sexualité en se disant
qu'à cet âge là ils n'ont pas encore de
relation alors que pourtant ils sont
déjà très exposées à des non pas des
images de sexualité mais des images de
violence et érotiser
donc comme ça a été dit long nous faire
croire que la pornographie et ex
inoffensive et que c'est juste un
fantasme ben non c'est effectivement
déjà pas du tout une offensive mais
vraiment des choses aux films et mais
c'est enfin des choses des violences
réelles mais c'est extrêmement banalisée
donc c'est une zone de non droit non
seulement dans la loi mais aussi dans
les esprits souvent on dit non mais
c'est de la pornographie ça compte pas
une chose qu'on dit souvent notamment
sur internet c'est si si ça existe il ya
du porno dessus donc à la pornographie
de tout le moindre chante asthme le
moindre désir l'os le plus pervers est
représenté et existe donc voilà un homme
qui peut-être voit une télévision une
femme politique qu'il n'apprécie pas à
trouver une vidéo pornographique qui
représente une femme qui lui ressemble
tout existe vraiment vraiment vraiment
et quand c'est à un clic voilà quand un
enfant de 11 ans peut juste aller sur
son ordinateur et aujourd'hui son
smartphone et trouver ça c'est très très
inquiétant
en plus avec ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
de la plasticité du cerveau les enfants
sont encore plus déjà les adultes sont
extrêmement haut conditionné et ça nous
reformate wallace a vraiment sa
programme reprogramme le cerveau de
regarder ces choses-là essarts programme
la façon de considérer la sexualité
donc dans l'étude de 2010 est plus de la
moitié des jeunes interrogés considèrent
que la pornographie fait partie de la
construction de leur sexualité donc
essayez encore sans considérer toutes
les influences donc inconsciente qui
sauter sur eux et surtout quand on sait
que quand on est très très jeune on
absorbe tout ça de façon encore plus
forte que les adultes
donc un garçon qui cherchent des
informations sur la sexualité et va
tomber sur la pornographie va apprendre
que les femmes aiment la violence s'il
va apprendre que les lesbiennes m
coucher avec des hommes et apprendre que
celle la pénétration donne du plaisir et
la pénétration anale doubles ou triples
et banale est très facile
que le plaisir de l'autre ne compte pas
il va apprendre plein d'endroits où
excusez moi le terme était acculé
déposer son sperme des endroits très
créatif il va apprendre qu'une ville
vous disent sans poils aux lèvres
symétrique et c est la norme et il va
ressentir aussi a ressenti va apprendre
à ressentir de l'excitation envoyant une
femme en larmes en voyant une femme
complètement dissociés aux yeux vides
puisque souvent pour supporter toutes
ces douleurs et toutes ces violences les
femmes victimes de prostitution sont
complètement drogué et sous sédatifs
donc faut différencier quand même une
influence que ça peut avoir sur les
garçons et les filles on parle beaucoup
de la chance de la pornographie sur les
garçons et sur la façon ça leur apprend
la violence et c'est très très important
d'en parler mais sur les filles on a
quand même une inégalité très très forte
chez les femmes sont les victimes de ces
violences en prostitution et donc les
filles qui regardent la prostitution
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup et les
femmes vont apprendre qu elles sont
quelles vont être victimes de deux
jeunes ans que la sexualité va être des
violences pour elles elles vont
apprendre qu elles sont utilisables et
pénétrable sans compter toutes les
violences qui peuvent s'exercer sur elle
par les hommes qui on regarde
d'autant plus que comme il a été dit
montrer de la pornographie à une jeune
fille fait aussi partie de d'un procédé
de pour ensuite exercer de la violence
et une violence elle même par ailleurs
donc ces jeunes n'apprendront pas tout
ce qui est indispensable à la
construction d'une sexualité saine comme
le plaisir la découverte de l'autre le
désir la communication le respect la
tendresse n'apprendront pas
une sexualité égalitaire surtout entre
entre hommes et femmes et n'apprend pas
à comprendre leur profond ressenti et à
savoir s'il ya du désir et ensuite à
dire non s'ils en ressentent le besoin
donc je dépasse peut-être mon temps je
vais essayer d'aller vite
on il faut il faut aussi estimé c'est
très important que l'on exposé à la
culture pornographie même quand on ne
regarde pas donc les enfants baignent
vraiment dedans dans cet univers qui est
aussi dans les films dans les jeux vidéo
dans la publicité et je vais dans les
comportements des gens autour d'eux même
si eux mêmes non non non je devienne pas
un bouquet suffit pas de dire moi je
regarde pas je suis pas influencé
c'est de plus en plus courant de voir
des gars ont essayé avec leurs
partenaires des pratiques qu'ils ont vu
surtout si c'est comme ça qu'ils après
ma sexualité apprennent entre guillemets
et qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre donc c'est
vraiment c'est ça la sexualité donc
c'est ça que je vais faire un autre
exemple il m'a donné une militante il ya
quelques semaines elle est professeur et
un enfant de 13 ans est venu d'avoir
paniqué en dix ans mais je comprends pas
a écrit l ont mal ils étaient terrorisés
par l'idée que la sexualité ce soit ça
ils voyaient de la violence il a compris
que c'était de la violence extrême et ça
va être ça c'est à ça que les enfants
sont exposés donc soit ils apprennent
que c'est comme ça et que ça va être
violent et ils peuvent ressentir de la
peur ou l'internât lisez dans les deux
cas c'est juste extrêmement dommageables
sur leur construction et leur bien-être
enfin ça a été évoqué un petit peu mais
important il est important de rappeler
que l'addiction à la pornographie est
très puissante c'est une drogue dure qui
en plus utilisent l'outil de très très
puissant de conditionnement de l'orgasme
et donc les jeunes vont apprendre très
vite avec désensibiliser avoir besoin de
contenus de plus en plus violents pour
ressentir de l'excitation et aussi
apprendre à être à être ressentir du 2-2
l'excitation face à des choses qui sont
violentes et donc appeler une espèce de
dissociation
et à vraiment être dé sensibiliser
les golden dossier a travaillé
énormément sur la dessus entre en
expliquant aussi que l'on peut mettre ça
à l'échelle de la société puisque les
contenus aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
extrêmement extrêmement violent et
encore plus qu'il ya encore quinze ou
vingt ans
donc on voit que plus les jeunes
s'habituent au scénario mis en scène
dans le porno okoor également à ce que
la durée des débats parler aussi de la
performance et les 410 mais j'arrive pas
à avoir une érection aussi longtemps par
exemple et pense que tout ça est normale
est attendu d'eux
edel donc plus à finalement il n'arrive
pas à construire la sexualité qui est
complexe est vrai avec avec des vraies
personnes
et donc il est vraiment urgent urgent
urgent de développer une autre culture
de la sexualité donc on peut passer par
la loi mais ça passe aussi par une
éducation sexuelle vraiment complète et
qui parle pas seulement de contraception
mais qui parle aussi de relations non
hétérosexuel qui parle de désir et parle
pas seulement de consentement oui ou non
mais de savoir si on a envie ou pas être
à l écoute de ses désirs comment
découvrir son corps est su de l'autre et
qu'on soit quelque chose de vraiment
égalitaire merci d'abord à vous tout
parce que vous êtes engagés d'un dans un
combat politique qui est extrêmement dur
voilà c'est dur pour vous je sais que
c'est dur de visionner les vidéos par
exemple voilà on dort moins bien voilà
on sort pas intact comme les policiers
qui travaillent sur la brigade la
pression avec quatre démineurs ne sort
pas intact de ski de ce qu'ils voient
enfin ceux qui travaillent sur la
cybercriminalité et c'est donc et puis
c'est un combat qui est pas facile parce
que c'est un combat cas c'est contre
courant de certaines libertés
libéralisme esprit liberty un
libéralisme comme quoi la pornographie
l'accès aux images pornographiques et
quasiment un droit de la personne voilà
et
comment on peut aujourd'hui affronter ce
phénomène qui disons le clairement au
cours des dix dernières années après une
dimension pas simplement numérique en
volume mais aussi dans nature
totalement différente de ce qu'on avait
connu et identifié par le passé donc
merci a vous vous savez que soutient et
d'ailleurs ce rapport de la délégation
des femmes s'inscrit aussi dans le
soutien à ce que vous faites pas
possible que les élus que nous sommes au
contenu de détourner pudiquement les
yeux de ces sujets là vous avez besoin
de soutien des juges ont besoin de
soutien tout ce kit qui affronte sa en
besoin de soutien alors voilà ceci étant
dit
plus de remarques la première c'est que
nous ferons des propositions
pour dire les choses assez clairement
c'est vrai la loi existe on peut se
poser la question de savoir s'il est
suffisante pourquoi la question
essentielle est suffisante va être posée
parce que de toute façon
l'énergie que demandent les actions en
justice et la sanction telle que la loi
aujourd'hui est faite est trop grande
elle est disproportionnée est trop
inégal par rapport à ce que vous
affrontez est-ce qu'il faut affronter
le wat 2016 existe sur la prostitution
est il de vous dire qu'on connaît on a
fait ensemble le constat de la faiblesse
de son application
donc là on a peut-être d'autres options
légales juridique mais je suis très
perplexe sur la capacité que nous avons
collectivement à mener les enquêtes les
instructions et l'énergie qu'il faut
pour faire tout ça donc on se posera
cette question là je suis très fière à
ma collègue laurence peine que je ne
suis pas sûr que non puisque l'éducation
quelle qu'elle soit puisse faire
contrepoids à la puissance
de l'image pornographique chez des
adolescents qui de toute façon
nous avons fonds vont être beaucoup plus
attirés par ces images que par le pauvre
discours de la militante associative qui
va venir faire leurs deux d'éducation à
la vie affective et sexuelle
quand c'est comme ça a lieu non mais
mais chez mec c'est parce que tu voulais
dire mais j'ai un doute sur notre
capacité collective
faire contrepoids à tout cela tant que
c'est accessible tant que c'est
accessible c'est ça que je veux dire
tant que ces textes si on peut pas
lutter voilà on peut pas lutter si des
images sont là c'est soit importé des
jeunes se sont à portée des adultes
aussi parce qu'à pâques les jeunes que
ça concerne cas aussi les des hommes des
hommes et des femmes des hommes qui
trouvent là renforcer une certaine image
de la sexualité et des femmes qui
ensuite viennent chez les psys et
demande qu'on a raconté à plusieurs
reprises compagnon existe ce genre de
pratiques est dit que c'est normal
est-ce que c'est vrai et qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'elle est la norme de la
sexualité que la pornographie impose
aussi aux femmes est donc dans ce point
de vue là c'est un élément important de
la culture du viol pour parler un
langage qu'on parle voilà donc on va je
crois que notre merci d'abord ce qu'on
fait notre travail va normalement vous
appuyez et on exposera je crois toutes
les questions
sans tabous et moi pour ma part je suis
assez peu sensibles au discours sur des
libertés individuelles
des hommes et qui regardent des films
pornographiques est la vraie question à
mon sens c'est tout qu'est ce qui est du
cinéma qu'est ce qu'ils n'en aient pas
en fait la pornographie c'est du snuff
movies voilà c'est c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le qualifier et
pour donner une piste
comment on peut essayer de déployer la
jurisprudence morsang-sur-orge arrêt le
plus connu du conseil d'état s'il en est
sur la question de l'industrie
pornographique en fait est ce qu'on peut
est ce que la société accepte que soient
accessibles en france puisque c'était
notre sujet des images qui sont non pas
du cinéma cirque ils ne sont que
qu'elles ne sont pas des images inquiète
les gens feignent quelque chose mais qui
sont des images de réalité est-ce que
nord est ce que c'est normal que on
accède à des images dans lequel une
pénétration n'est pas simulé mai et
effectué je poserai on dit là et tombe
sur ces sujets là faut être très radical
pour arriver à obtenir la moitié de ce
qu'on veut
merci beaucoup chers collègues je passe
la parole
la rapporteure alexandra burke you
fantin qui est un vision avec nous à
alexandra c'est à toi
oui merci annick bonjour à tous et en
particulier aussi aux intervenantes et
merci infiniment pour pour cette
expertise qui va bien sûr l'écart
éclairer nos travaux et et qui était ô
combien puissante ma question en fait
c'est surtout relative à la relation sur
le voile à la relation de pornographie
et prostitution je voulais axé ma
question si vous voulez bien plutôt sur
les étudiants on voit que la
précarisation des conditions étudiants
qui ne cesse de s'exacerber d'autant
plus avec la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons depuis maintenant presque
dedans est ce qu'il existe des données
qui permet de mesurer leurs coûts à la
pornographie et ses étudiants et
étudiants pour clôturer fin - est-ce que
vous pouvez nous éclairer de façon on va
dire plus générale sur le lien entre
universités et l'industrie de la
pornographie dans celles où on fait en
tout cas que ce phénomène prenne de
l'ampleur
alors je vais vous laisser répondre à
ces aux questions des trois rapporteurs
et ensuite je passerai la parole aux
sénateurs sénatrice qui est non demandez
vous organisés comme vous le souhaitez
donc madame ah oui alors je vais juste
répondre rapidement sur la question de
l'éducation
parce que en effet je pense que je suis
d'accord que ça ne pourra jamais
contrebalancer bien sûr complètement
mais néanmoins ça reste très important
que dès le plus jeune âge il n'est une
éducation qui soient proposées aux
enfants sur toutes les questions
de légalité et notamment et
le problème c'est que ce que nous
constatons c'est que ça fait des années
et des années et des années qu'on en
parle et on essaie de le faire d'autres
sujets pour que de manière globale on
travaille sur les stéréotypes sur les
relations filles garçons sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles et c'est
qu'on puisse parler les choses à chaque
niveau en fonction de bien sûr de l'âge
des enfants mais ça ne rentre pas la loi
de 2016 qui a été évoquée prévoyait
également que que chaque élève et à un
moment donné dans son parcours scolaire
une des interventions de prévention sur
tout ce qui est marchandisation du corps
mais on attend toujours ça n'a jamais
été fait c'est pas faute de le rappeler
est donc je j'ai peur qu'on n'est pas
aujourd'hui la capacité
alors nous on le voit dans les
interventions qu'on fait en milieu
scolaire l'éducation nationale nous dit
on est tellement sollicité il faut faire
venir la prévention sur la drogue sos
suicide
bien évidemment le travail sur de lutte
contre l'homophobie et c est en fait ils
nous disent si on arrive à vous faire
venir une fois tous les trois ans est
bien donc il faudrait que ce soit
vraiment dans le corpus en fait
éducatif de l'éducation nationale et on
n'y est pas du tout donc c'est voilà
c'est juste ma réserve m bien sûr qu'il
faudrait que ce soit fait
et puis je voudrais juste rajouter une
petite chose avant de laisser mes
collègues répondre
je voulais juste dire aussi que par
rapport à effectivement le
déséquilibre entre ce que l'on peut
faire et ce à quoi on s'attaque on a
parlé ça a été dit que c'est une
industrie
colossal
pornographie et bruce titution ce qu'on
appelle l'industrie du sexe il ya des
intérêts économiques tellement énorme
que la répercussion en est que bien sûr
que nos opposants sont plus financés que
nous par exemple et donc on a aussi un
déséquilibre en termes de moyens pour
pouvoir agir et ça c'est extrêmement
frappant et c'est aussi une grosse
difficulté est d'autant plus que cette
industrie-là des répercussions sur
d'autres on ne l'a pas abordé je ne
voulais pas prendre trop de temps mais
sur les répercussions sur les jeunes et
pas que les jeunes il ya aussi toute
cette industrie qui se développait dans
la chirurgie plastique
puisque pour pouvoir ressembler à ce qui
est montré dans la pornographie on a
énormément de jeunes qui vont avoir
recours à la chirurgie des vulves au
plastique des hommes qui vont se faire
opérer pour allonger le pénis c'est
évidemment tout ce qui concerne les
opérations chez les femmes au niveau des
seins de la bouge tes lèvres etc et qui
sont
voilà qui ont explosé avec le
développement de la pornographie je n'ai
pas de chiffres pour la france juste
parce qu'il met mes camarades en ont
mais je sais que au canada une enquête
avait été menée là dessus il y a déjà un
certain nombre d'années et qui avait
montré à quel point la progression de la
diffusion de la pornographie et la
progression des demandes en chirurgie
juste pour tout ce que j'ai cité était
extrêmement importante et était
parallèle mais que celles chez les très
jeunes donc adolescente explosait donc
il y avait vraiment une demande de
chirurgie chez beaucoup d'adolescentes
pour ressembler à ce qu'on voit dans la
pornographie donc ça veut dire que c'est
des industries aussi qui en maniement
d'autres et que cdd voilà c'est des
profits énormes qui va être
effectivement dit il de contrer et je ne
serai pas plus loin
merci beaucoup je vais passer la parole
à claira charlès qu'il avait souhaitée
puis ensuite madame céline pic oui merci
beaucoup c'est pour rebondir sur la
question de l'éducation donc moi
j'entends manama rossignol que ça c'est
pas suffisant je suis assez d'accord
mais je nous on a toujours pensé que
c'était primordial même au delà de
l'accès de la question de la
pornographie voilà de nous on demande sa
aux effrontée depuis plusieurs années on
avait une pétition qui avait dessiné par
d'autres associations c'est à dire qu'il
faudrait mettre en place vraiment pour
nous des programmes très ambitieux
d'éducation contre le sexisme à
l'égalité et sexuelle de la matériel de
la maternelle au supérieur et évidemment
ça impliquerait un certain budget et
c'est un peu toute la question en
général l'application des lois c'est lui
j'ai je voudrais juste rappeler aussi
que pour ce qui concerne l'éducation
sexuelle il ya déjà une loi qui est la
loi aubry ii 2001 et on sait qu'elle
n'est pas appliquée et cette loi prévoit
en fait trois heures l'information
sexuelle par an et par un niveau je vous
apprends sûrement rien du tout mais je
rappelle juste dons par an et par niveau
et c'est même une recommandation en plus
qui est venu plus tard parle convention
istanbul que la france a ratifié en 2011
et on a même été enfin la france a été
si je puis dire épinglé par le regio sur
un très long rapport d'une centaine de
pages de oui je crois très très bon
rapport de 100 pages qui mettait
justement en exergue le fait de cette
non d'application et ça c'est toujours
quelque chose qu'on me demande de
l'ensemble des associations féministes
c'est déjà commencer par appliquer les
lois qui sont déjà existantes et
évidemment qu'est ce qui pêche en
général dans la non application des lois
c'est la question du budget est très
rapidement en 2016 le haut conseil à
l'égalité disait que le budget aux
droits des femmes en fête représentait
seulement 0 0 06 % du budget global du
gouvernement ce qui évidemment
extrêmement peu et je rappelle aussi
qu'au début du quinquennat matheron le
budget alloué aux droits des femmes a
été amputé de 25% ce qui est énorme
je ne sais pas ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui mais je sais qu'il n'ya pas
eu d'augmentation réelle malgré si je
peux me permettre des annonces qui ont
été des mains des banquiers notamment
par un rapport sénatorial d'ailleurs des
annonces de marielle de marlène schiappa
qui ont vraiment été débloqués par cette
année sénatoriales et aussi par nous
tous temps et caroline de haas et nous
on ne cessera jamais osé france et dans
les autres je pense de le répéter c'est
que sans budget on n'applique pas les
lois c'est évident et on les effets
d'annoncé qu on entend souvent des
gouvernements souvent ne ne se
concrétise pas parce qu'il n'y a pas de
budget annoncé je pense que kevin pic
[Musique]
appuyé sur et puis ensuite madame
goolsbee alors je vais pas revenir sur
l'éducation sexuelle puisque beaucoup de
choses ont été dites moi c'était sur
notre capacité à faire appliquer la loi
alors j'entends bien par rapport au
procès aux qualifications de
proxénétisme
on a quand même là
je pense le plus gros procès de
l'histoire en terme de violences
sexistes et sexuelles on a quand même
trois juges d'instruction 500 hommes
incriminés et 50 victimes donc c'est
quand même quelque chose qui va marquer
et puis qui va montrer aussi la chaîne
de responsabilité du producteur jusqu'au
diffuseur donc c'est essentiel et puis
quand même en a un on a quand même des
leviers d'action extrêmement simple
pardon
alors nous on a fait des signalement au
procureur nos associations ont fait des
signalements ensuite suite au
signalement il ya eu des enquêtes et
ensuite des femmes victimes ont appelé
en fait quand quand effectivement il ya
eu des éléments qui sont sortis dans la
presse disant qu'une ouverture avait été
ouverte un autre association en
particulier a été un peu
submergé par des appels en dix ans mais
moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi je veux
témoigner et c est donc on est
aujourd'hui à 50 victimes identifiées 36
qui se sont constituées parties civiles
c'est ce que dit l'article du monde 1
vraiment l'article du monde reprend très
très bien les choses il ya je pense une
vraie mobilisation autour de ce procès
qui sera essentielle mais en attendant
au delà de cette question du procès et
des pratiques de proxénètes
et de façon vraiment réellement piéger
un pied j'ai manipulé et contrainte à
des tournages qu'elle ne souhaitait pas
faire il ya des choses qui sont assez
simples à mettre en place qui sont même
pas beaucoup très très très coûteuse
c'est quand même à un moment de bloquer
un certain nombre de contenus c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui si vous avez une
vidéo d'apologie du terrorisme ou pire
une vidéo de dèche on a des moyens
aujourd'hui on peut faire en tant que
particulier des signalements afin rose
et puis l'action publique enfin on peut
agir pour bloquer une vidéo et c'est ce
qui est fait et heureusement que les
vidéos d'apologie du terrorisme ou les
vidéos de terrorisme de décapitation etc
qui sont mises en ligne sont
effectivement bloquées quand je vois que
sur port noble ya encore c'était quoi le
chiffre
2462 vidéo dont le mot-clé ces tortures
pourquoi c'est encore en ligne c'est
très simple on a la possibilité avec les
ai failli deux blocs et cesser ces
contenus pourquoi on accepte encore des
vidéos donc le pied tous et inceste
pourquoi donc ça c'est pas très
compliqué à faire il faut simplement un
peu de volonté
donc
effectivement on peut
on va on va peut-être laissé parce que
du coup c'est pas compréhensible pour
les gens il semblait donc on va
envisager que c'est exactement cette
piste là et puis j'aimerais bien que
l'on s'unisse un peu tous et tout autour
du csa là parce qu'en fait on comprend
pas bien ce pourquoi ça n'avance si peu
rapidement il ya quand même une loi sur
la protection des mineurs et donc la loi
n'est pas respectée le csa a mandat de
bloquer les sites qui refuse de mettre
en place un contrôle d'identité
les contrôles d'âge on le fait pour les
paris en ligne voit pas pourquoi le
ferait pas pour la pornographie ça
traîne les mises en demeure ont été
lancés sur cinq sites dont les a saisies
sur 118 sites il ya un moment va falloir
que le csa aussi se bouge pour mettre en
place ces contrôles auprès des mineurs
et ensuite les vidéos de qui sont
manifestement illégal on a aujourd'hui
la possibilité de les bloquer comme on
fait
bloquer des des scènes de torture qui
serait diffusé donc les pros l'aps
annales l'un cesse les fentes and
familiale les scènes de torture les
scènes où les femmes hurlent à l'essai
nous les femmes son enceinte de huit
mois violée par huit mecs ce n'est plus
possible que ça soit en ligne et ça on a
tous les moyens pour le faire et pour le
faire rapidement voilà donc ça va être
aussi des pistes qu'on va qu'on va
explorer à osez le féminisme et puis
enfin
j'aimerais dire aussi l'absence de
moyens c'est un peu david contre goliath
là on est en fait trois associations
féministes
fait deux militantes bénévoles quand
même faut quand même le dire et on est
en train de porter un procès qui est
gigantesque où on va être partie civile
et en face on sait bien que ils ont
embauché des batterie d'avocats it vidéo
par exemple alors je lis maintenant its
business news et dans it business news
les frères paco donc quand même deux
français qui détiennent la deuxième
grosse plateforme après pornhub qui
s'appelle x vidéo qui encore plus trash
que pornhub eh ben ils ont les a
rappelés ils ont ils ont recruté les
meilleurs lobbyistes américains pour
contrer l'interdiction du csa et la
compagnie havas pour faire leur campagne
de com et essayer de passer
à travers les mailles du filet qui en
train de se resserrer autour d'eux donc
en fait on a des gens qui ont
effectivement des millions en lobbyiste
en avocat en communiquant et qu'en face
ce serait bien un petit peu que la
question des droits des femmes soient
davantage financé pour que le combat
sera un peu moins inégal et aujourd'hui
nos structures sont en difficultés
financières on peut le dire et non pas
du tout du tout du tout les moyens pour
mener les luttes qu'on estime être
légitime à mener voilà donc je suis ravi
que le sénat ne nous entendent et nos
écoutes mais on est aujourd'hui
tout petit c'est vraiment david contre
goliath et on n'y arrivera pas comme ça
il va falloir de la volonté
effectivement politique pour bloquer les
vidéos qui sont manifestement illégal et
là j'espère que le sénat aura toute sa
place à jouer dans ce dans cette lutte
voilà pour cette audition au sénat
d'associations féministes au sujet des
violences sexuelles dans le monde du
film pornographique à ces associations
ont dénoncé je cite un système de
proxénétisme industriels c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
continuer à suivre l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur public sénat